when you were offered the Mandalorian
did you have any say on the episodes
that you got to direct or was it sort of
like would you like to direct the
Mandalorian and here's what you will do
if you say yes I had gone down to visit
Favreau on the set of season one
Mandalorian uh because everyone was
talking about the volume technology I
love Star Wars and I love favro
um so when season two came about you
know John called and said would you like
to come down an episode I was like yeah
absolutely
um it was the second episode of season
two that I originally signed on for
um and John had written sort of a rough
script and then I fleshed the script out
and we worked on it together uh and then
uh that was the first one we shot for
season two it wasn't the first episode
aired but it was the second episode it
was the first one we shot and um they
were psyched about it and they had this
finale coming up uh which all he said
was we're gonna take a there's gonna be
sort of a big swing in in the finale I
was like what they got going on and uh
he said it's going to be a very
emotional episode and he sort of talked
me through it was about and I read the
script I was like absolutely I'm doing
this we already started I think you know
working on the script and formulating
quantumania uh but it was still early on
and we had Thomas like I I cannot pass
up this chance because obviously you got
to work with the volume technology how
much was it when you were on set
directing the Mandalorian we were like
oh I'm using this on quantumania well it
was a technology I wanted to know about
right and I wanted to see you know how
it worked and and sort of how it could
be applied so I didn't necessarily
specifically think but it was definitely
in the back of my mind you know we're
going to do quantumania and we have to
render the quantum realm vividly there
were things that I wanted to do but I
wasn't sure that uh the volume
technology was ready for it what it was
great about on Mandalorian is you know
shooting these great location backdrops
and then putting out there and it feels
very photo real but we were going to be
creating digital backdrops some based on
on unreal photography but it was a
different thing altogether and we also
wanted a lot of movement within those
screens so we ended up you know using
the volume technology it was it was
great for certain environments but not
necessarily right for other ones there's
also um just uh size and shape uh things
that that sometimes our sets are too big
for the volume so we would use partial
sets so it was definitely one of the
tools we used in our toolkit and the
actors love it right because they get to
see a version of what they're going to
see in the movie and uh you know the
interactive lighting is obviously great
but it's great the actors love it uh but
you know it's it's not always the right
tool but I liked it because we wanted to
create all these different parts of the
quantum realm that had to look and feel
differently so it was cool to have some
that were and some that weren't